hello american-made Hollywood keeps
going they can have the coke Cinematic
Universe the Escobar Cinematic Universe
um design I'd be interesting I'd watch
it american-made so american-made is a
movie based on the true story of Barry
seal played by Tom Cruise Barry seal was
a pilot in the late 70s I his entire
story takes place between the late 70s
and mid 80s he's really good at his job
then a member of the CIA played by
domhnall gleeson comes out dem he's like
we need you to run guns to Nicaragua to
arm the Contras down there yeah contrast
learn something new every day about a
title then while he's doing that very
well making money on the side for his
family he gets the eye of Pablo Escobar
is like while you run guns and then when
you're going back to America you want to
go ahead and smoke a blow for us and
after that although what you will is
interesting now and this movie is
straight up on cruise control Tom Cruise
is he's one of the best there's
something about this guy he's
captivating he's charismatic you have
Tom Cruise a role and he will
straight-up run with the role most
likely he will literally run with the
role but in the vein of blow it was
interesting to see how these drugs made
their way to America and how the US
government was very directly involved
with it how it's like war on drugs
just say no however we're gonna go ahead
and do this other thing that's not at
all gonna be linked to drugs so look at
that it is this is very fascinating to
me in blow Johnny Depp is like I was
Escobar's guy and an American made Tom
Cruise is like I was Escobar's guy
apparently Escobar had quite a few guys
out there that meant nothing to him they
were all just mules what can I say an
eye for talent they got the job done for
sure this is another one of those bio
pics it's just it's an interesting story
you didn't know you wanted to say she
didn't know the story even existed as
interesting as the movie was there was a
bit of a pacing issue in here usually
pacing means the movies just too
drawn-out in this case there's a lot
happens at a very short amount of time
before you know it you're like oh it's
the next year and then before you know
it's the year after that but really it
feels like he's been doing this for
about two months max made the movie feel
a little jumpy in part american-made is
an interesting spiderweb of details and
events that chronicles this phase in the
cartel like Escobar and his guys they
were kind of small-time at this point
there's so many irons in the fire in
here it's hard to concentrate on one but
you can't just concentrate on one all of
them are interconnected and it was
really cool to see I am glad that they
concentrated on everything all the cogs
in the wheels you can't take one cog out
of here the whole thing will fall apart
you need all these elements to the story
fascinating look in the war on drugs
that's probably a more accurate look
than the US government's probably gonna
give you why would they give you this
side of it it would not behoove them to
give you that I will say american-made
is worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray all right guys so american-made
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]